[Musique]
je vous demande tout votre authenticité
votre sincérité pas de filtre fermer les
yeux
concentrez-vous et si vous ressentez la
moindre petite peur vous fermez pas les
yeux quand je vais dire un mot lever la
main vous êtes prêts ubu risation ouh là
là il y avait main levée ça va sucre et
nos emplois
l'ubs et risation c'est comme les robots
ça va nous transformer en matrix
c'est honteux de faire travailler des
gens 70 heures par semaine
mais oui c'est clair c'est vrai ça fait
peur mais moi je suis intimement
convaincu que l'ubs et risation et
peut-être sous certains aspects une
vraie opportunité vers un monde de paix
je vais vous expliquer étincelles s'est
produite un jour je sortais d'un
rendez-vous bien stressé je suis monté
dans un vtc et là j'arrive slimane
bellum boga belle barbe tout sourire
m'ouvre la porte ma vie ta rentrée dans
son taxi ni qu'elle me donne une
bouteille d'eau me dit de ne pas
m'inquiéter
et là mon stress tombe j'ai envie de
sourire
mon regard sur lui change et il commence
à expliquer sa vie comment ce job de
taxi a changé son existence lui à qui il
n'avait jamais été donné l'opportunité
d'avoir un job avant lui qui travaille
60 heures par jour le mec il bosse 60
heures par jour par semaine est là qui
suivent
et il a le sens du service et slimane il
ya une reconnaissance pour ça le fait de
lui avoir donné une opportunité de
bosser et maintenant ils envie d'être
reconnaissants envers les autres et ça
se sent quand on est dans sa voiture
après avoir passé dix ans aux états unis
monthey et revendu plusieurs sociétés de
technologie d'internet à 40 ans j'ai
revendu ma dernière entreprise
je suis rentré en europe j'ai quitté san
francisco suis revenu en europe et me
suis rappelé de cette petite étincelle
en me disant waouh 6e slimane arrive à
changer le regard des gens dans sa
voiture à travers une expérience de vtc
et si on faisait la même chose mais pour
tous l'emploi et si on arrivait à hub et
reese et où l'emploi est ce que ça ne
serait pas un moyen d'arriver à redonner
à chacun la chance de trouver un job et
peut-être de connaître plus de monde
mais je voudrais faire une petite mise
au point
qu'est-ce que libé risation ça sonne
souvent avec précarisation évasion
fiscale esclavagisme moderne c'est des
termes qu'on entend souvent
moi je pense que comme tout changement
de paradigme économique
on l'a vu dans les années 30 la
révolution industrielle il faut une
régulation et bien souvent les états
sont longs à légiférer et maître du
temps et pour arriver à suivre les
révolutions industrielles
là nous assistons à une véritable
révolution industrielle et ça va prendre
un petit peu de temps mais je vais
revenir sur ces trois concepts
précarisation
certes ces emplois ne sont pas des
emplois en cdi
mais savez vous que les vététistes en
france depuis cinq ans ont créé dix
mille emplois
dix mille personnes au boulot et il faut
savoir que parmi ces dix mille personnes
il n'a plus de 80 % qui n'avait aucun
job avancer leur premier job et l'autre
majorité pour qui c'est un deuxième job
donc est ce qu'on parle vraiment de
précarisation sachant que dans le même
temps je ne crois pas qu'un seul des
taxis français été mis au chômage en
tout cas pas dix mille dans les cinq
dernières années
donc on n'est pas en train de détruire
des emplois pour en créer d'autres on
n'est pas en train de précariser des
emplois on est en train de créer des
nouvelles opportunités pour des
personnes qui n'avaient jamais vu jamais
eu accès évasion fiscale c'est pareil je
pense que les choses vont se régler
oui il ya des abus c'est certain je vais
prendre l'exemple de cette plate forme
de location de saison immobilière
jusqu'à très récemment ne collectait pas
les taxes d'habitation
le gouvernement leur a demandé de
régulariser c'est après quelques années
et maintenant ils collectent au nom de
l'état les taxes d'habitation
ça se réguler c'est pas que ces sociétés
soient là pour casser les codes fiscaux
c'est que pour aller vite
compte tenu du temps que les états
mettent à légiférer
ils prennent juste la vente mais
systématiquement derrière ils
régularisent donc n'ayant pas peur de
cela
troisième point l'esclavagisme moderne
là encore soyons prudents faut tout de
même savoir que dans les années 30
les ouvriers se sont mis en se sont
réunis en syndicat pour combattre pour
se réunir être plus fort face aux grands
industriels
il se passe exactement la même chose
l'ensemble des prestataires d'investis
cistes ou d'une plate forme qui lui
brise la location immobilière se
réunissent régulièrement
encore récemment on a eu des exemples à
paris
deux chauffeurs qui se réunissent
ensemble qui crée une sorte de syndicat
2.0 et qui arrivent à faire pression
pour arriver à diminuer leur soit leur
horaire soit augmenter leurs salaires
donc ça s'organise aussi ce que je veux
dire par ici c'est que précarisation
évasion fiscale et esclavagisme oui
c'est sûr on peut voir ça comme ça mais
si on essayait de regarder toutes les
bonnes choses qui se passent par
ailleurs mais il la régulation qui
arrive c'est pas si grave que ça et ce à
quoi je voudrais m'adresser
m'intéressait maintenant c'est la bonne
partie libéralisation libéralisation
s'est donnée à chacun quel que soit son
âge quelle que soit sa profession quel
que soit son expérience quelle que soit
son origine
la capacité à pouvoir créer son propre
job sans forcément avoir de diplôme
je vous donne un exemple j'ai mon permis
de conduire
je suis dynamique j'ai un peu de temps
et j'ai pas de job je peux prendre du
jour au lendemain un job de taxi un
autre exemple tu fus bien née j'ai de
l'argent j'habite à new york
j'ai un appartement disponibles
inoccupés je peux louer mais également
je suis un pauvre gars sur les bords du
nil qui a su s'adapter à internet et
pareillement je peux grâce à ces
plateformes mettre à disposition la
location devant ma petite cabane à un
touriste japonais probablement au même
tarif voire plus cher que l'appartement
de new york
alors qu'avant c'était juste impossible
et mieux encore je suis un designer
super talentueux j'habite dans un seul
homme un bidonville à new delhi j'ai une
connexion internet au cybercafé
peut-être chez moi je peux désormais
proposer mes services au même prix que
n'importe quel designer international à
des sociétés européennes ou américaines
c'est pas une vraie opportunité sa de
donner à chacun où qu'il soit la
possibilité de pouvoir trouver un job et
et à travers l'insertion dans le travail
une véritable distance sociale parce
qu'il faut savoir que c'est pas possible
c'est pas uniquement pour ce genre de
service
mais on peut également être coiffeur
être prof conseiller fiscal comptable
bricoleur dépanneur mêmes médecins
grâce à ce genre de plateforme jusqu'ici
il fallait un diplôme
imaginez-vous pour monter un salon de
coiffure il faut un cap2 coiffure on n'a
pas le droit d'avoir un établissement de
coiffure en revanche avec une plateforme
hub here is an la coiffure on le peut de
la même manière je reprends l'exemple du
taxi aujourd'hui vous voulez faire taxi
il faut quand même débourser 50 milles à
200000 euros pour acheter votre plaque
alors évidemment si vous voulez
d'un côté soit il faut avoir de l'argent
et beaucoup d'énergie pour arriver à
créer son propre business dans le monde
traditionnel soit il faut se résigner
entre guillemets à essayer de trouver un
job est là dans beaucoup de pays
notamment la france pour trouver un job
il vaut mieux de vianne et de la bonne
couleur venir du bon endroit et avoir un
peu de piste on essaie salubre isation
quel que soit votre âge
quel que soit votre origine quelle que
soit votre lieu de naissance
quel que soit votre couleur de peau
quelle que soit la beauté de votre
visage moche beau quel que soit votre
religion
vous avez la même opportunité de pouvoir
travailler à distance et avoir un job
comment ça marche
en fait ça marche essentiellement à la
confiance la particularité de ces
plateformes c'est qu'elle crée un
environnement de confiance à travers
trois outils essentiellement le premier
c'est la recommandation
le deuxième c'est la certitude d'être
payé un environnement c f secure de
paiement et le troisième c'est la
progression personnelle je vais revenir
sur la recommandation
vous voyez bien sûr toutes ces
plateformes les prestataires bien
souvent sont recommandés par d'autres
personnes
et au fil de l'eau chacun des
prestataires va bâtir sa propre
réputation va étendre son réseau et va
de lui même arrivé à bâtir un
environnement de confiance de personnes
qui lui ont fait confiance donc plus il
avance plus il donne de la confiance à
travers le réseau la certitude d'être
payé toutes ces plateformes ont des
solutions de paiement sécurisées avec un
des solutions de remboursement si ça ne
fonctionne pas et figurez vous que je
discute souvent avec les taxis qui ne
sont pas des taxis vététistes ib risée
mais les taxis à l'ancienne est une des
raisons pour lesquelles bien souvent
sont pas toujours très agréable c'est
qu'ils ont la trouille et nous un truc
de clients ce bar sans se payer est
effectivement entre le cas de figure
vous êtes dans une voiture dans laquelle
la solution et sécuriser la place
la personne a été recommandée on sait
qu'elle est est chic et 5 étoiles à la
fin la transaction sera payée il conduit
ici claude à partir de ce centre a payé
et l'autre solution dans laquelle on
sait pas qui on a affaire
ban dans une voiture ça sent bon ça sent
pas bon le gars ne sais pas s'il va être
payé il a trouvé que le client parts
c'est plus tendu et la progression la
progression
c'est le plus important c'est plus pour
votre employeur que vous bossez c'est
pour vous c'est plus dynamique
c'est votre propre progression que vous
maîtrisez plus vous travaillez plus à
vous renvoie plus à étant votre réseau
et ça c'est primordial
saissac et révolutionnaire c'est que
désormais vous prenez votre vie en main
et vous travaillez non plus comme je le
disais pour un employeur mais pour créer
votre propre progression personnelle
chaque investissement que vous mettez
dans votre travail
ça développe votre réseau et ça je pense
que c'est vraiment révolutionnaire
alors certains cercles c'était un petit
peu provocateur
parce qu'effectivement c'est pas si
simple l'ubs et risation fellah titres
des journaux fait les titres des
journaux il ya des grèves et des gens
qui sont bloqués mais ce que je voulais
illustrer ici c'est en revenant sur ma
petite expérience avec slimane slimane
que je n'aurais jamais eu l'occasion de
rencontrer parce que slimane ils
habitent dans les cités comme 90% de ses
chauffeurs btc il n' barbe moi je suis
plutôt un verbe haut le gsm me laisse un
peu pousser les poils mais ça me fout un
peu la trouille légalement débarque dans
les cités je l'aurais jamais rencontré
et pourtant
sliman il m'a offert une opportunité
unique pendant 20 minutes on est resté
dans un huis clos
on a parlé on est en confiance et je
suis sorti de l'armé en miroir original
j'ai eu envie d'aller rencontrer ses
potes et je suis sorti de là la première
chose que j'ai fait c'est que j'en ai
parlé à d'autres personnes en dix ans
mais regarde ça a changé mon regard se
ce qui se passe dans les cités
ça a changé mon regard sur cette espèce
de d'un mâle gamme qu'on peut lire dans
les médias souvent sur ce qui se passe
dans les cités et je pense que c'est
peut-être ça aussi le beau risation la
capacité à faire rencontrer des
personnes qui n'avaient jamais
l'occasion de se croiser dans un vase
clos de confiance dans un environnement
qui leur permet d'interagir de mieux se
connaître
sécuriser et d'échangés je vais pas vous
dire que suis tombé amoureux de slimane
sortant de la voiture mais je les
bien-aimés
est-ce que c'est pas ça le début aussi
de la paix commencez à s'aimer les uns
les autres
alors oui je vais un peu provocateur
mais je pense que l'ubs et risation et
ses plateformes
si elles sont bien maîtrisés dans un
cadre de confiance ça peut véritablement
être un chemin vers la paix
[Applaudissements]